newest sexual harassment scandal in
Washington hits a well-known Democratic
senator Minnesota's Al Franken is asking
for an ethics investigation into his own
behavior a talk radio news anchor
released this 2006 photo of him touching
her chest while she slept
LeAnn tweetIn says Al Franken also
forcibly kissed her while they were
putting on shows for service members
overseas
the former Saturday Night Live writer
and performer apologized in a statement
saying I'm sorry I respect women
I don't respect men who don't senators
from both parties including Republican
leader Mitch McConnell and Democratic
leader Chuck Schumer urged the ethics
committee to investigate CBS News
reached out to 16 women who used to work
for Al Franken in the Senate we heard
back from six of them and they say they
never witnessed any inappropriate
behavior Julianna Goldman is on Capitol
Hill with a fallout Juliana good morning
good morning senator Franken kept a very
low profile here yesterday but meanwhile
across the country Leon Sweden was
recounting in great detail how she was
victimized by Franken before he became a
US Senator he grabs the back of my head
and just sort of comes in and puts his
lips right on mine and just sticks his
tongue in my mouth
according to LeAnn tweetIn just minutes
before their first USO show in Kuwait
Al Franken kept insisting they rehearse
a skit he had written that included a
kiss and I'm like don't you ever touch
me like that again tweetIn says she
didn't see this picture of Franken
appearing to grope her while she was
asleep until she returned home what if
that was your daughter or your sister or
your mom is that funny
on Thursday Frank instead of the picture
I look at it now and I feel disgusted
with myself it isn't funny it's
completely inappropriate his Democratic
and Republican colleagues who last week
passed a bill mandating sexual
harassment training in the Senate said
the alleged behavior was inexcusable so
far I had not only about the press
reports but I'm troubled about that it's
not fitting behavior for anyone Franken
mentioned the 2006 US autre on the
Senate floor in 2010 I was kinda coho
with a beautiful woman named Leanne
tweeting but he's also said his sense of
humor is sometimes more fitting for
late-night TV staff sometimes has to say
okay okay owl let's keep it here in the
room yeah the question I wrote this book
the answer a question I get asked a lot
which is is being a United States
Senator as much fun as working on
Saturday Night Live and the answer is no
why would it be talk radio hosts and
frankenz home state of Minnesota took
him to task if you're a pervert you're a
pervert
doesn't matter if you're a Democrat or a
Republican you're still a pervert and it
still needs to stop Franken says he'll
cooperate with the ethics investigation
but it's still hard to know what his
future in the Senate holds these
allegations are now part of a wave of
accusations of sexual misconduct across
Hollywood across politics across comedy
and Nora Franken straddles all three all
right
Juliana thank you so much